affaire grégory depuis que le président
ciment a pris en main l'instruction se
prenaient à espérer que trois ans après
les faits la vérité allait bientôt
éclater aujourd'hui le magistrat a
procédé au bord de la vologne à la
reconstitution des conditions dans
lesquelles le corps de grégory a été
jeté dans la rivière
didier pouillot fr3 lorraine la montagne
a accouché d'une souris par trois fois
le mannequin spécialement préparé pour
l'occasion a été jeté dans la vologne
toutes les précautions avaient pourtant
été prise
ils étaient munis de bras de jambes
était habillée d'un pantalon d'un
blouson de chaussures et d'un bonnet
toutes les conditions requises pour
qu'il représente le mieux possible le
corps de grégory
ça n'a pas été suffisant par trois fois
ce mannequin a coulé immédiatement ou
après avoir parcouru quelques dizaines
de mètres est ce que l'expérience se
déroule près du passage à niveau en
amont de celle où près du barrage à
l'entrée du village
concluant pour les avocats de la défense
ces résultats ont cependant été
contestée par les avocats de la partie
civile
déjà sceptiques quant aux conditions de
cette expérience ils ne m'ont convaincu
qu'il y avait de grandes difficultés a
estimé analogues
le corps d'un être humain
et puis une substance inerte si bien
reconstituée soit elle par rapport à
corps humain placé devant cette nouvelle
polémique qui répondant à la demande de
la partie civile le président simon a
utilisé un deuxième mannequins sans bras
ni jambes plus légers celui ci a flotté
sans problème
mais s'il a franchi les obstacles de la
vologne il en a également enregistré les
traces jeté depuis le passage à niveau
depuis le barrage depuis l'affluent de
la vologne
ce deuxième mannequin aura finalement
servi à tester les différents endroits
susceptibles d'être considérés comme les
lieux du crime
mais le président simon pourra-t-il en
tirer des conclusions qui ne soient pas
contestées par l'une ou l'autre des
parties
à la fin de cette journée les
interprétations de la défense et de la
partie civile et herat
également opposé les certitudes que le
magistrat était venu chercher son enclos
loin d'être établie et le sort de
christine et jean marie villemin qui
sont restés toute la journée à la mairie
de sel est loin d'être scellé